pasamos al fútbol porque por estas
fechas transcurren de manera simultánea
la copa américa femenina celebrada aquí
en colombia y también la eurocopa
femenina en la tierra para analizar esos
partidos estar con nosotros ahora castro
director ya de deportes de caracol radio
y el diario 'as' colombia bienvenidos
ahora es un gusto estar con ustedes como
siempre comenzamos con la copa américa
porque hemos visto cuatro partidos y
ocho equipos en estas primeras jornadas
de la copa américa femenina sin duda
brasil ha mostrado estar un peldaño por
delante de las demás estamos destinados
a ver ya la octava copa américa para la
canarinha es muy difícil negar el
poderío y el potencial que tiene la
selección brasilera esto porque
históricamente como bien lo indican esos
siete títulos que ya posee y han
dominado el torneo han dominado el
torneo por recursos por algo más de
estructura en los años anteriores y por
tener referentes como marta que si bien
no está en esta copa ha hecho mucho por
el fútbol brasilero sin embargo yo creo
que esta es una de las copas más parejas
es una copa muy competida porque varios
de los países varias de las federaciones
ya han empezado a invertir en recursos y
lo que ha demostrado estos jugadores es
que una vez tienen recursos el nivel
competitivo aumenta y parece muy
interesante colombia que vienen de ser
campeonas panamericanas y que estando en
casa tienen esa responsabilidad
un poco de reiterar este proyecto que
llevan con altas y bajas lo de venezuela
me parece interesantísimo con pamela
conti como entrenadora y una de lina
castellanos que es una figura rutilante
del fútbol femenino chile también lleva
un proceso interesante y sumaría ecuador
un ecuador que tanto en hombres como en
mujeres está haciendo una estructura muy
sólida de su fútbol y con emily lima sin
duda van a competir entonces es muy
difícil poder quitarles el rótulo de
favoritas a las brasileras pero sin duda
haber equipos que van a intentar ponerle
piedras en el camino por lo menos para
llegar hasta esa final el jugador que
hasta el momento ha protagonizado el ajo
la mayor huella en este torneo una copa
américa últimamente muy disputada mucha
atención a chile que la veremos ya en
acción este lunes en su debut en este
torneo vamos a hablar de ahora de la
eurocopa porque la eurocopa ya hemos
visto a varias favoritas también hay
muchas favoritas en esta eurocopa ya
vemos españa ya vimos a países bajos a
francia a noruega a las propias inglesas
es también una copa augura una eurocopa
muy disputada muy disputada a ver one si
nosotros nos vamos al mundial 2019 de
los 8 equipos que clasificaron a cuartos
de final solo eeuu que fue el campeón
estaba fuera de europa ahí tenemos a
noruega inglaterra países bajos alemania
suecia italia es decir que ahí está la
élite del fútbol femenino en este
momento en europa españa llegaba con
dudas aunque con un equipo muy favorito
por lo que lleva haciendo como hace el
barcelona sin embargo la salida por
lesión del ex putellas puso un poco de
presión sobre ellas pero ganaron 4-1
finlandia es decir que siguen en su
camino como favoritas hay que ver más
como en otros partidos que tácticamente
les represente alguna dificultad mayor
pero muy bien para mí una de las grandes
favoritas es las anfitrionas inglaterra
se llevaron a la técnico que fue la
técnica que fue campeona de la anterior
eurocopa con países bajos creo que su
potencia muy bien un equipo de jugadores
experimentado y además un equipo muy
acompañado por el público 73 mil
espectadores en su debut ante austria
esto habla del potencial que hay y sobre
todo lo que están movilizando estas
mujeres francia con una de las ligas más
potentes en la liga que tienen los
campeones de la champions pero no han
logrado en en estos torneos ni en
mundial en eurocopa a dar el golpe
clasificaron en las tres últimas
ediciones a los cuartos de final yo creo
que esta puede ser su
digamos su torneo porque las jugadoras
ya tienen la experiencia necesario para
llegar a este tipo de instancias y
alemania- superfavorita dos veces
campeonas del mundo ocho de esos
campeones de europa sin duda van a ver
dar de qué hablar e iniciaron este
torneo con goleada yo creo que es un
torneo muy disputado y los invitamos a
todos porque yo creo que el nivel del
fútbol femenino no sólo ha mejorado
insisto yo creo que en la medida que hay
recursos la competitividad aumenta y
estamos viendo un fútbol de élite y
sobre todo muy acompañadas de las
tribunas el sueño europa sobre todo lo
comentábamos antes que hemos visto una
buena parte de afición comentamos
entonces que esperemos aquí en esta copa
américa de colombia conforme avance el
torneo veamos también un poco más de
apoyo en esas dudas y mayor difusión
para este torneo yo creo que el mundial
de 2019 que se disputó en francia empezó
a hacer a darnos ese nivel no sin duda
en conmebol tenemos aún
un rezago un rezago desde los recursos
un rezago si nosotros hablamos de premio
no se comparan los premios de la
eurocopa con los de la conmebol sin
embargo este año ya hay premio de dinero
lo cual indica que hay un avance la
brecha va a ser muy difícil de cortar de
un día para otro pero creo que tanto
domínguez el presidente de la conmebol
que estuvo aquí en la inauguración se ha
dado cuenta de lo que pueden mover estas
mujeres y yo creo que su voz y todo lo
que han hecho no sólo en el fútbol
colombiano sino el fútbol del exterior
está empezando a mover lo que pasa en el
fútbol sudamericano y yo creo que esto
que estamos viendo hay un par de equipos
que podrían ser los más débiles de estos
días que están compitiendo pero el resto
van a demostrar que con una estructura
sólida y con ese apoyo y sobre todo la
gente va a empezar a animarse mucho
viendo el gran nivel que están mostrando
es importante recordarle a la gente que
en colombia todos los canales regionales
los canales públicos están transmitiendo
la copa y sin duda esto es importante
para el desarrollo de este deporte en el
país así es ahora gastro como siempre
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en
deportes domingo